Hello, and welcome to today's episode. Today, are
taking a look at Crossplane,
a tool for managing infrastructure
using the Kubernetes API.
We have some familiar faces joining us today.
We have Dan and Marcus.
Welcome to the stream again.
Thanks for having us on. No. I'm I'm
very excited. We've we've tried to find a
date for the team for a little while
now, and I'm I'm just glad that we're
actually getting to sit down and play with
this stuff together. It's gonna be awesome. Sure.
I think I think the the intro is
upgraded maybe since last time I was on
here. That was pretty cool.
Yeah. I mean, it's
it's getting a bit old for me now.
I see it too much.
Yeah. I bet. But I I'm I'm happy
with it. And at the very least, it
gives me an opportunity to click the buttons
that I need to click over here. So,
you know, to keep some mystery around the
show. But Right.
So I think what we should really do
is just start
with the
what is Crossplane?
Cool.
Well, I'll I'll take that, and then, Marcus,
you can just chime in wherever you see
fit.
But, essentially, it is, first and foremost, a
way to provision infrastructure
using the Kubernetes API.
So
most people come to Crossplane
initially
because they'd like to
provision infrastructure on cloud providers or on, you
know, any sort of hosted infrastructure provider
from the same API that they use to
actually deploy their workloads and that sort of
thing, and they'd like to be able to
connect them up easily and that sort of
thing.
So, generally, we'll see folks compare Crossplane to
tools like Terraform or Pulumi or things like
that.
But it's a bit different for a number
of reasons.
And the first being I think Marcus and
me just switched positions there.
The first being that it's running as as
well, the different components of it are running
as Kubernetes operators. Right? So they're constantly reconciling
your state as opposed to traditional infrastructure as
code tools where it's just kind of like
a one shot, you know, and then when
it's done, it lets you know. And then
it continues as the the provider sees fit.
Crossplane, on the other hand, is going to
continuously reconcile your infrastructure.
So a lot of times, we'll demo someone
provisioning, like, a database or something like that,
and someone going in and modifying part of
it and then seeing it brought back to
the desired state as put forth in the
Kubernetes cluster.
So that's definitely kind of, like, the initial
intro. It's usually pretty easy for folks to
understand
as well, and it provides value to people,
which is great.
On top of that, Crossplane itself, all all
of the kind of provisioning of managed services
is kind of in a plug in model,
which we'll see in a little bit with
the Equinix metal
provider that we're gonna look at today.
But, you know, there's different providers for for
all kinds of different infrastructure hosting platforms.
And then the core part of Crossplane
is essentially a package manager, which allows you
to install
different types of packages, one of them being
providers. So after you install Crossplane, you can
say, you know, add GCP support, please, and
it'll bring the CRDs and controllers and that
sort of thing.
And the other
being composition,
which is where you take all of these
different managed resources,
these granular things that represent actual APIs on
a cloud provider, and you compose them together
into abstractions
for, you know, developers within your organization to
interact with.
And then you can package those up in
a separate kind of package, call it configuration,
and install those.
And what you get is kind of a
a platform as a service that you're defining
the abstractions yourself.
So today, we'll look at kind of, like,
the the maturation process of using Crossplane. So
starting off with, you know, maybe just looking
at provisioning a device on Equinix metal and
then
moving towards, like, packaging that up and being
able to reproduce your platform across Kubernetes clusters
and that sort of thing.
Nice. So, I mean, it it sounds really
cool. I'm looking forward to this. Like, I
guess we have the ability to represent all
of these infrastructure components using Kubernetes CRDs.
And I guess the the the really cool
side effect of that is I can now
get up to my infrastructure
by having something continually apply those CRDs in
my cluster, and then the Crossplane controllers just
go and make the world happen. That's kinda
what we're looking to do here. Right? Right.
Yeah. Very very declarative.
And another thing just kind of, like, going
along with that is, you know, standardization on
the Kubernetes API gives you things like GitOps,
but also gives you things like policy.
So one of the things we really love
is showing off using Crossplane with Open Policy
Agent, you know, when you're writing granular rules
that apply to CRDs that are created. And
so you can say something like, you know,
don't let anyone create a database
that's larger than 20 gigs or something like
that. And you can write these kind of,
like, arbitrary rules that apply to any type
of infrastructure, especially when you write abstractions. Right?
So if you have a database abstraction,
and behind that, you have Cloud SQL, RDS,
Azure database,
whatever.
You can make a policy for that abstraction,
and then everything flows through that and you
can kind of, you know, put barriers or
firewalls, if you will, for actually creating infrastructure
with different policies.
Yeah. I mean, I'm gonna be honest. I
often turn a blind eye to policy, our
back end security, and I know that that
is is not the way to be doing
it. I'm looking forward to learning today.
Well, I mean, if if you have the
the privilege of not having to worry about
it, then I'd say just keep rocking with
that. That sounds pretty good to me. Oh,
yeah. I'm really lucky that all I need
to do is spend things up for a
short period of time and go look at
cool and then disappear and shut it back
down again. Like Right. So but
of course, security is really important.
And I definitely use seccomp every week now.
I promise.
So
let me pop up my screen.
Marcus, did you wanna add anything to to
that description? You obviously have some context around
Crossplane as well. Yeah. Yeah. And I also
connected
I disconnected from a VPN, which is why
I switched Windows with you for a moment.
So, yeah, I I think what I'd add
is that, you know, when you when you
compare things to Terraforms, that Terraform is something
obviously,
it's not doing the continuous reconciliation
loop.
But
trying to manage Kubernetes
with
with Terraform
is maybe not as easy as it is
to manage Kubernetes resources from inside of Crossplane
when it's serving the same sort of purpose,
especially when you're interacting with
clients
clients and any kind of application in Kubernetes
that is going to need to have access
to those cloud resources that you're provisioning.
In the case of
Google and Azure
and etcetera etcetera and Amazon,
you're talking about Microsoft
you're talking about, like, MySQL services,
things like that where having the having the
credentials
be provisioned inside of your cluster and then
be consumed inside your cluster is super convenient.
In the case of this Equinix metal
provider,
what we're provisioning is, like,
very raw resources. We have bare metal hardware,
and we have networking resources.
And
sort of the sky's the limit with that.
And in terms of
how ready this is, like, earlier,
David, you you alluded to how we could,
like, provision everything. Right now,
only a few of the only a few
of the resources that Equinix Medal offers are
available
in this provider.
But
it's an open source project. So, obviously, if
anybody wants to contribute more, great. Otherwise, we're
sort of, like, adding them in as as
we find the need for them.
Well, it's October. Right? So, you know, any
any resources we identified today, were, like, gonna
be really cool if the provider supported us.
You know, then hopefully, the people watching are
happy to come along and and help us
out there. And, of course, if they want
any help in return, they can head us
all up on Twitter. I'm sure we'd be
happy to help them contribute
to the project. Definitely.
So
there was a question that's kinda spinning in
my head then right now. We've we've now
mentioned things like Pulumi and Terraform a couple
of times here. And I I I'm wondering,
you know, as a developer responsible for some
sort of set of or some subset of
production infrastructure,
which does Crossplane
replace that or augment it? Like, do you
see all infrastructure provision happening for the Kubernetes
API with Crossplane?
Do you need to bootstrap stuff with another
tool? I mean, how does this workflow work
in reality, not just
in my head? Right. Absolutely. That's that's a
great point. And and the first thing I'd
say to that is that
I don't think Crossplane is for every organization
or every person, and I definitely would not
recommend someone do it. You know, if you
are using a tool already
and it serves every need that you have,
then I would stick with that. I would
not, you know, churn and and try and
switch to something else. So that that would
be the first thing.
The second thing is I think that the
these tools can coexist together. In fact, we've
seen a lot of people
use
Terraform's
kind of Kubernetes
provisioner where it basically allows you to spit
out, you know, arbitrary CRDs, but you write
the manifest using HCL.
We've also seen this with CDK to where
you're basically writing Kubernetes manifest using TypeScript.
That's a great example. We actually have a
video of of Kelsey Hightower provisioning Crossplane resources
using the Terraform provider.
So I definitely think these these can play
nicely together. It is a a pretty fundamentally
different model,
and I think that Crossplane gives you more
benefit as you scale to a larger organization.
Obviously, if you have things coming up and
down really quickly,
you you have a benefit there
kind of with that GitOps flow that you're
talking about. And then the other thing would
be if you have a large organization
where you're trying to provide kind of, like,
a self-service platform to developers as opposed to,
you know, you have your infrastructure team and
they open a ticket and do it. The
idea with Crossplane is that a developer has
a cluster that they connect to, and they're
presented with these abstractions
that you've defined for them, and then they
can self-service infrastructure. And that's where some of
that policy and stuff can come in. So
yeah. I I absolutely think that that these
tools can play nicely together and actually
can be used together for the same use
cases.
So I I wouldn't recommend folks,
you know, completely drop one or the other.
I'd say evaluate your circumstances and see how
you can use them together. I'm very diplomatic
if you can't tell. That was a very
fancy way of saying it depends. Yeah.
Well, we had to fill an hour and
a half somehow. Right? So
So the the thing that's going through my
head again, You know, I love to externalize
every single thought I have is that one
of the biggest challenges I have using tools
to Terraform and Ploom, as great as they
are, is that if my infrastructure doesn't change
too much Mhmm. And I I'm not making
another change for maybe a few days or
a few weeks or worst case even months
is that by the time that we run
that plan and apply is that so much
could have changed in the state of the
real world. And I guess that problem of
having to do a refresh of the state
and then the world kind of disappears by
using a tool like Crossplane because the reconciliation
look is is always running. Is that right?
Yep.
That's as good as answers I need. Perfect.
As long as your Kubernetes cluster is running,
yes. Yeah. That's true. That's true. Well, I
I guess,
to kind of amend my my previous answer,
if you're not using Kubernetes at all,
I think Crossplane could still be valuable to
you. But you obviously you know, Crossplane runs
in Kubernetes.
So if your organization is literally not touching
Kubernetes and has no plans to, maybe not
the right tool for you. Well, that was
until someone on Marcus and I's team, Jason,
was
working on a bad idea, which I saw
that.
Is I think it's such a really cool
thing for projects like this and for the
cluster API where you want that declarative
Kubernetes API without a full fledged Kubernetes cluster.
So Mhmm. I I'm looking forward to seeing
that hack hack come forward one day, the
proof of concept. Yeah.
Alright. Let's let's get started. Right?
As always with this stream, I tried to
do very, very little upfront. Now what I
have prepared just because we need a Kubernetes
cluster is I've used the cluster API
to spin up a Kubernetes cluster on Equinix
metal with three master nodes and three worker
nodes. I've since been told that's maybe a
little bit overkill, but we're gonna have a
little bit of fun with it anyway.
Now just to confirm that I haven't broken
anything in the last five minutes. If I
run key get notes,
we're gonna see the view of our Kubernetes
cluster from this point of view. I haven't
done anything else. I've not installed Crossplane. I've
not got the CRDs. I I I have
done nothing. So this is where
I need the guidance. So I'm on the
website. I'm assuming there's really good documentation and
I'm hoping we can click on the docs
page and start with the something really simple.
That sounds great. Do
I need a Crossplane CLI or do I
need to just
compute control applies and manifest to my cluster?
So to install
well, actually, to do anything with Crossplane, you
don't need the CLI.
We'll probably go ahead and install it
just to make things a little bit easier,
especially some of the things I'm gonna show
later about with the CLI. You can actually
build these packages, which are very opinionated OCI
images.
So it can do some of that for
you. So you don't have to use it
by any means,
but would recommend
installing.
Okay. So I can skip together Kubernetes cluster.
I can Mhmm.
Okay. So I'm not gonna skip installing Crossplane.
So
it wants me to use helm.
What's it what's helm three alpha and helm
three master? So alpha, we have two different
channels of release.
Alpha is gonna be our latest stable
release, which this doesn't
the the naming of these channels, I think,
is confusing.
But I guess as a pre one dot
o project,
you know, maybe you're not calling it stable.
But anyway, master is gonna be literally the
the latest helm chart built from master, and
alpha will be the the latest release. So
helm helm three alpha there is gonna give
you a Crossplane version 0 dot 13. O.
Now I know that you've both been really
busy working on this provider this week. Does
that mean we're working off the master branch,
or are we working off the the alpha
cut? We're on alpha. Zero dot 13 was
actually released on Friday, so it's pretty fresh.
Sweet. Okay. So first of all, I'm creating
a namespace.
I'm adding a Helm repository.
I like it when I just have to
copy and paste from the docs. Yep. And
you can we're not gonna use OAM today.
So if you want to turn off the
OAM flag, you can, but you don't have
to. It'll just What what what is o
OEM? OEM is kind of like the application
level layer
of Crossplane,
and it's it's a general spec. And and
then Crossplane is just the Kubernetes implementation of
it that basically allows you to have kind
of, like, a higher level abstraction over, like,
deployments and pods and that sort of things.
You can define an application and then for
sure it consumes.
But so it kind of goes, like, the
managed resources, which are granular reflecting the cloud
provider, then composition,
and then OAM, which would be like, how
do these compositions play in with, know, an
actual application
that we wanna run?
Alright. I mean, I'm still conflicted about whether
I want it because one side of my
head is saying, send the documentations. Another part
is going, you don't really need it. So
Well well, you I I would say if
you wanna do application stuff, you need it,
but
I don't think we're gonna touch on it
today, at least from what I have planned.
But we we can if you'd like.
Well, you know what? Screw your plan. I'm
good with it.
I respect it.
Yeah. Don't complain about my credentials. They're fine.
Can you think of any kind of application
we can make happen with the resources available?
I don't think so. OAM is earlier in
development than Crossplane,
so I don't think that they have a,
like, target for a bare metal machine. I
think it's it has to, like, target the
Kubernetes API. So we could run them directly,
I guess,
in in cluster, but the the infrastructure consumed
likely
wouldn't be
something provisioned on Equinix metal.
K. No worries. So let's run our GET.
We've got
pods,
deployments, replica. Alright. Okay. Alright. So we've got
something running. Mhmm. And you're saying this will
be easier if I install the CLI,
and I love nothing better than piping to
a shell. So
It's very safe.
Yeah.
And then you'll need to move that to
your path if you want up there.
Okay.
So
oh, so this is a cube control plug
in? Yep. Yep. So if you move it
to user local Ben up there, it should
just you should have Kube control cross line
working.
And I could have installed it with crew.
You
use the the Kubernetes plug in manager or
no?
The I think, Marcus, he wrote the original
Crossplane CLI, and I think it was compatible
potentially.
This this new one is is not yet.
Yeah. I had the crew
version of it installed, but I don't recall
if it if that was just running off
of a local branch against crew or if
that was merged into crew.
There we go. We've got more Hacktoberfest
ideas for anyone watching this.
For sure. Also, I am going to
you have some of these commands here to
get started.
Packet or Equinix metal is not included in
the documentation here, so that's something we definitely
like to do once we have CI set
up and that sort of thing for for
Packet.
But instead,
I'll just put some commands here in our
shared
editor,
and and you can just run those.
So first, what we're gonna wanna do is
install the packet
or the Equinix metal provider.
And like I said, we don't have CI
set up for that right now, so I'll
just let you install my own build of
that. So you're gonna do cube control crossplane
install provider,
and I believe it's at
Ashtan
Crossplane
provider
Equinix.
We were going back and forth on how
long this name should be before it started
annoying people. Yeah. So if you run that,
you we should be good to go though.
Alright. So this is using the Crossplane CLI.
It's installing a provider, and this reference on
the end, I'm assuming, is a container image
on maybe the docker registry. Yep. Absolutely.
And and as you're doing this, I can
kind of explain a little bit about how
this works.
So in the case of a provider,
what you're installing is some CRDs and a
controller to reconcile them,
and you're gonna have some collisions on the
provider name. So if you do, just do
k get p k g or k get
Crossplane would also work. But k get p
k g will will get you all the
packages,
that are installed
or it should. Let's see. Yep. Yep. So
look, it it's installed and healthy.
So essentially, what's happening behind the scenes is
this package is an OCI image, basically just
has a configuration file
and a bunch of YAML and a stream
in it. It's a single layer OCI image,
and it has also a reference to a
separate image, which is the controller that we're
gonna actually install and run.
And and what it does is the Crossplane
package manager, which is part of that Crossplane
pod we saw running,
when it sees the creation of a provider
resource, it's gonna look at the source of
it and see this image, and it's gonna
pull that image and extract
kind of the package configuration for it. And
from that, what it's first gonna do is
say, hey. Can I install all of these
CRDs and control them? Right? So in Kubernetes,
you have owner references and controller references.
Controller references are basically just a special type
of owner reference,
and there can only be one controller of
a resource type.
And so in this case,
there is no other providers installed,
so it will easily gain control of these.
So first, the package manager is gonna say,
can I install all of these CRDs and
be the controller of them? If so, it's
gonna go ahead and create them. And then
if it creates them all successfully,
then it's gonna start a controller to reconcile
them.
If it's unable to say that I'm gonna
be able to gain control of all of
them, it's gonna say, hey. This isn't installable.
This is gonna conflict with another another provider
you have, and that kind of guards you
from, you know, having providers fight over control
of resources.
Okay. Cool.
So you can see I'm having a nosy
now to see who the CID that you've
you've thrown into my system here. So the
OEM stuff, we can maybe try and talk
about at the end.
I won't try to deviate from your plan
too much.
Well well, I will do whatever you want.
So this is your show.
And then we've got the Crossplane extensions down
here. So we've got our providers,
configurations,
the same as the basis, virtual networks. Okay.
Mhmm.
And, yeah, those those packet ones are specifically
the ones that came. So if you if
you had run k get CRDs
before we install the provider
Equinix metal, those packet CRDs wouldn't be there.
We need to update those that API group
as well now.
But
now that it's installed, it brought those and
installed those. And if you actually, you know,
described one of those CRDs there, you would
see a controller ref to the provider revision,
which is the installed version of the Equinix
metal provider.
Does that mean I have a pod running
now? It's a the Equinix
metal pod? Yep. Crossplane. We do. Yep. Yeah.
And you'll see that has kind of a
a hash and then kind of the stuff
that the deployment does to do the randomized
UID.
The hash there is actually the hash of
the or the digest of the OCI image.
So since we're using this actually kind of
dangerous except for that we have control over
the docker,
image. We're using a latest tag here. So
what would actually happen, we have different types
of on the provider, type, there's different types
of policies you can have for update.
So if since we're using the latest tag
and the default policy is auto update,
if I pushed a new OCI image that
had different configuration in it
with the latest tag, Crossplane would automatically
go and see that on a reconcile
and say, oh, I see there's a new
version of this provider available.
And it would create a new revision for
it,
and it would transition ownership
or controllership,
I guess, of those resources to the new
one.
And you can also customize that to say,
create the new revision, but don't transfer controllership.
You know, don't start don't switch out the
controllers,
etcetera.
Okay. That makes sense to me. That was
that was, like, 2 that represents,
like, over over the years to work and
thinking and and ideas
scratching.
Yeah. So, yeah, I'm I'm really glad to
hear that explained so concisely.
Yeah. Yeah. It it definitely has been a
long road.
And and Marcus did a ton of the
work on the original package manager.
And in this new release, we kind of
redesigned it from the ground up and it
enabled some of the stuff that that
there's a bunch of issues assigned to me
that you had originally created.
It was fun to get to close out
some of those.
And things that are coming in future releases
are actually some some advanced dependency management and
that sort of things you can
especially with configuration packages, which we'll look at
in a minute, you can depend on providers.
And it'll say, like, install my configuration with
my abstractions,
And these abstractions are serviced by provider Equinix
metal and provider AWS, and it'll automatically
go ahead and install those providers for you.
Okay.
So let me see if I understand where
we are at the moment then. Cool. We've
got Crossplane running on a cluster. We've added
the Equinix metal provider and that has opened
up three CRDs that we are now going
to start playing with, I'm assuming,
which is server VLAN imports.
So is there a next step now that
we're gonna deploy something? Is that what the
configuration you just mentioned was or is that
something else?
So we can
yeah. Actually, to to go ahead and let's
let's jump to the end and then work
our way back. You want to? Or is
that
does that work? We can we can show
the the simplest workflow and then go back
to sort of, like, the more granular stuff
you can do. I mean, it's just my
intuition is telling me I I've installed Crossplane.
I've added my provider. I've not given any
token yet. I'm assuming there's something I have
to do here, and then I can say,
hey. Go get me go get me a
server. Like, I want some bare metal. Yep.
Absolutely.
So do you wanna go to the
provider packet
kind of GitHub page, and we can look
at the read me, which will show you
how to do your explicit credentials for
Equinix metal?
I'm I'm gonna try and not call it
packet as much as possible, but it's really
hard. I'm gonna be honest.
Packets are those things that go over the
network. Right? Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. That could be
confusing. Yeah.
Alright. So this is the
yeah. This is the provider. Okay. Cool. Mhmm.
So, yeah, if you do the the credential
setup there, install that Equinix metal provider. Yeah.
There you go. So we already ran that
command beforehand,
but with my own personal image.
Alright. So in order for me to do
this, what I now need to do is
that's gonna be Linux instructions, isn't it?
Yeah. If you if you just set API
key equal to your API key, you know,
just the the variable, then the next commands
are gonna work. Alright. Let's move the magic
over here.
Alright. So export
API
key.
I still have the YAML for that tank
deployment.
If we want to go crazy, but we
probably should go crazy.
Actually, some of this new stuff,
excuse me, should actually make that a bit
easier, some of that stuff we're trying to
do with tank. So maybe we will look
at that in a little bit.
But I I'm also gonna have to load
back up on what we did because I
kinda pushed it out of my brain after
we included that one.
I'll jump. Thank you. Alright.
Guess we do wanna use it.
Cool.
Alright.
I just run PS because whenever I move
the window back to other display, always pull
the school buffer back and keep the screen.
So Yeah. I I've done that before as
well on some of my screens. Alright.
So I'm assuming the commands I need are
being typed into here.
Yeah. So so did you go ahead let's
see. You just created those environment variables. Did
you actually create the provider object there also?
Nope. I can do that.
Let's see. So yeah. Exactly.
So so what you're doing here is basically,
you know, just creating a secret and then
creating our provider object, which then gets referenced
by every other resource. Basically, every resource has
a provider ref. And this is a general
pattern for all of our providers.
It's just the way that you know, our
method of authentication.
We've also talked about and there's been some
some work recently towards having different back ends
than just a Kubernetes secret for authentication.
One of the things you can do, for
instance, if you're running provider AWS and your
Crossplane is in an EKS cluster,
they have things like I'm roles for service
counts
where you can just give the Crossplane pod
service count, you know, an annotation, and it'll
inject that into that.
And then on your provider that you create,
you don't specify a secret. You say, you
know, like, I think native is, like, the
the the type of authentication,
and the AWS SDK and the controller will
just say, oh, I'm supposed to look in
my file system and pull out this token.
Okay.
We're using that generic secret today, but that's
there are other options.
What I'm taking away from that. Yeah.
Exactly.
And you care about security, but of course.
Right. But, of course, you don't you don't
care about security or policy. Right? So we
we should be good today.
But if now you'll need to create an
actual provider
instance here,
which you'll see just below there, and then
we should be pretty good to go.
I was looking at another screen, but you
did do the the read into the environment
variables with the secrets?
I got yes. We're we're good there. I
mean, hopefully.
That was behind the scenes. Yeah. So
this is
I mean, I'm just gonna save this as
a fail because I'll probably push this up
somewhere,
and then I'll apply it manually. So this
is just API version Crossplane, and we create
a provider,
the project ID.
Oh, so that's been interpolated actually from my
bash environment. Alright.
Okay.
So I can't just take that off.
Or you can just paste it in. Yeah.
The project. Yeah. It's it's not a secret,
is it? Right. Okay.
And then we reference the
okay. We reference API token from the secret
that we just created. Right. Right.
Cool. This is This goes back to your
wanting to copy and paste from the instructions.
That's that's what this is all about.
And we're good. It's now being create
edit.
Nice. Okay.
So let's see what the instructions tell me
to do next. So this is we're now
getting into the the actual specification using CRDs
to deploy Equinix meta hardware now. Right? Right.
Although,
I will say, if we want to skip
ahead and go for the advanced mode, we
can we can skip this a little bit
and come back to it. Are you game?
I mean,
I do love advanced mode. So Alright. Well,
I I mean, I got that feeling from
you. So alright. Switch back over to the
editor.
Alright. And if you go to your read
me here,
I've put this command in here. And because
I think you're so awesome, I actually created
a Rawkode
configuration
package
before this
that is going to allow you to have
your own custom platform,
your Rawkode crossplane platform
that's consisting of Equinix metal resources behind the
scenes. I'm really playing this up. It's not
gonna be that cool,
but it will show the new functionality. So
if you run that command there,
let's let's take a look at what happens.
Hold on. Let's let's let's back up a
moment here right now. You're you're luring me
in with advanced mode. I get it. Right?
You're you're you're catering to my eagle. Right.
But you're also telling me that I'm not
security conscious, and then you get me a
random bit of YAML that you want me
to apply to my cluster. I know how
this works. Like, I know your game. So
I'm gonna look at this first, and I
know it's gonna interest you.
Yeah. The you're talking about the link above
this one. Right? Oh, yeah. No. I'm talking
about the command above this. You don't have
to this is this is Marcus. Marcus put
this link in here. He's the malicious one
here. So
In my demo. You just have to run
a simple CLI command that pulls an arbitrary
image from our registry. It's not near as
risky.
Uh-huh.
I mean,
I don't even have Docker run. Oh, no.
You you don't need it. You won't need
it.
But it says no such image. Are you
sure you pushed this image? Or do I
need to build it first? Does that how
Docker registry is worked. Right?
So, yeah, you can you can pull it.
So it looks like you got it there.
Created 292
ago, you can see.
But if you run this command, it it
will take care of everything you need for
you.
Alright. I'll trust you.
I'm not I'm not gonna start tearing apart
an OCI image just to pick up. I
all that's inside of this is three
one YAML file that is three resources concatenated
together. So we'll we'll look at the contents
in a minute.
Try
kubectl get package again, p k g.
I feel like I wanna watch this again
in, like, the the the behind the scene
commentary version of it and, like, ask Dan
what what's going on behind some of these
things? We're we're gonna go to all of
it. We're gonna get it all.
But what you'll see here is so we
had that provider that was already running. Right?
And then we now have this configuration package
type, is the Rawkode Equinix metal,
and it looks like it's installed and healthy.
So what we should see is run k
get CRDs
and
check and just to grab equinox.metal
or something like that.
Yeah. There we go. So this infra's resource
is what we wanna look at.
So, basically, what I've done is I've taken
a just a device resource. So we're not
composing multiple different types together,
but I've taken just the device resource and
create an abstraction over it. And if you
look at this, this is gonna be a
pretty small CRD.
Yeah. I think you're gonna need describe CRD
and then the name. Yeah. Yeah. Of course.
And it's only gonna have one field that
you populate.
And let me drop in actually in our
thing here.
Oh, so this this isn't this is a
CRD. It's not actually
Right. Right. An object of the of the
CRD type. Right. Okay. Right. We'll create that
in just a minute.
There we go. So, yeah, if you scroll
up, it's a
rather small CRD actually.
We we get a lot of the the
stuff here from the Kubernetes API.
But essentially,
it just has one field, and that's gonna
be your host name.
And if I can get Versus Code to
open this one second here.
I'm trying to see if I can get
another window open that's not the
the editor that we're in. We're basically gonna
create an instance of this
this info resource,
and we'll see what's happening behind the scenes.
But let me grab it.
And so that is great. Oh,
what we have here? So I just added
in here. So you'll see this is a
pretty simple resource here. Right? You just have
this one host name field and then write
connection secret to ref, which is just kind
of where we want the the information to
go if there's any output from
the infrastructure that this provisions.
But feel free go ahead and keep control
apply this in your cluster, and we can
see what happens.
Alright. So since we installed that CRD, we
can create instances of it,
and
we probably won't get too much information there.
It's not ready yet, but try a k
get
Crossplane.
It's a group annotation? Yeah. Okay. Alright. So
what you see here at the bottom is
a packet server device,
and you'll see that it synced true and
ready as false. And you'll see some other
information there, and you'll see that that host
name Rawkode live. If you switch over to
your
Equinix metal console, we should see this spinning
up also.
I think you can also k get
packet there.
Yeah. I couldn't remember if we added the
categories to this one or not, so I
I played it safe.
There we go. We have a
well, I mean, I would never spend up
a CentOS seven machine, So
you clearly don't know me that well, but
we do have a machine spinning up. Well,
let's you you wanna look at what happened?
I mean,
I said I was ready for advanced mode,
but I have no idea what just happened
here. So Right. Exactly.
Well well, the nice thing is you don't
really have an idea what happened, but you
got your your infrastructure going. Right? Which, you
know, you didn't have a lot of options
about what you could do here. You could
only customize that host name field.
But
what's actually happening behind the scenes
is I've created what's called an XRD,
a composite resource definition, which is kind of
akin to a CRD,
which defines a new type that we want
to exist. So generally, when you want a
new CRD type, you know, you create a
CRD object. Creating an XRD
gives Crossplane some information about going and creating
a CRD for you and starting a controller
to reconcile that.
And then we also have a composition resource
that
that satisfies that XRD, and that includes the
different actual, you know, manage resources, the device
in this case that are in that. So
let me go ahead and copy over into
the editor the exact contents of that package
that I had you
install there.
Yeah. So let me let me see if
I got this right then. Alright.
You've created you're you're storing something in an
OCI compatible fashion that is actually a collection
of resources that can be consumed by Kubernetes.
I'm assuming what I just did when I
ran
what did I run? Kube control crossplane.
Yeah. That's one here. Kube control crossplane install
configuration. That's configuration lives in an OCI registry,
but it's really just a collection of Kubernetes
resources that you're applying to my cluster for
me. So it's just a really convenient
I mean, it's essentially replacing comply fhtpsgethub.com
blah blah blah. Right? Is that Right. Exactly.
And as that grows to be more complex,
you get kind of more and more benefit
out of that.
And and also another thing you get is
the ability to kind of share this with
other people in an installable manner.
So,
I mean, I think as as people that
are working with Kubernetes, right, we're we're always
applying remote matter. Not always. Once
they don't care about security,
but generally sometimes apply in remote manifest. And
that's one of the challenges with that is
is that if you wanna be able to
modify that in flight before it has Kubernetes
API, you generally gonna need to do some
weird bash maneuvers or or download it and
make the modifications.
The first thing that struck me is cool
about the OCI format is do I have
a ways to inject configuration into the the
Crossplane configurate? Can I modify that configuration in
some way?
So as it's coming through,
right now, no. You could during that install
for providers, especially where it's actually creating a
deployment that's gonna reconcile them. We want to
make it so that folks can
go ahead and modify,
you know, how they how that's actually installed.
So kind of like install time configuration.
So I definitely think that's something that will
happen. One of the benefits you get of
installing via Crossplane
is that it's gonna do some validation for
you.
And so, like, if this OCI image, you
know, had a bunch of nonsense in it,
it's not gonna get applied to your cluster.
Right? Crossplane's gonna parse this and say this
is valid
or it's not.
And then you can kind of just go
from there.
But if if you hop over back to
the editor again, I've actually pasted the contents
of what's in this image
into
the configuration
directory here.
And so the first thing, what you're looking
at there is the composite resource definition.
So you'll see this looks a lot like
a CRD, but it's a little bit, you
know, scaled down.
And it's pretty simple. We're just defining a
new resource type called infra.
And so you saw that, you know, we
create an instance of infra. So the the
result of creating this composite resource definition or
XRD as we call it is for Crossplane
to create a new CRD for you
and for it to start the controller to
reconcile that. And that reconciliation loop that runs
watches for instances of these to be created,
and then it looks for compositions,
which if if you switch over to that
other file that I added.
This composition, you'll see, has a composite type
ref,
and it references that same XRD that we
mentioned, which basically says, I can satisfy this.
So you could have a number of different
compositions that satisfy a single XRD,
and that can be beneficial if you want,
you know, different types of configurations to meet,
you know, a a generic abstraction.
So once again, the easy one to think
of is if you had, like, an AWS,
GCP, and Azure kind of backing for a
a maybe, like, if or let's say in
this case, you had
this one which is Equinix metal
device, and then you also had one that
was like
a AWS EC two instance or something like
that.
On the XRD,
you could actually or on the instance that
we created of it, you could use a
selector, which will select it by label,
or you could reference one of those compositions
directly,
but all through the same resource.
And then in line in this resource or
in this composition here, you'll see we have
the device type. And then we have some
patches which are basically saying from that abstract,
go ahead and overwrite this field
in the body of this resource we have
in line.
And then also things like using these transforms,
which we have some simple transforms
for you to be able to choose the
name. So in this case, it's taking the
UID
of the
the abstract type, the input type we created,
and it's saying write the connection secret ref
for this object to that UID
post grad SQL, which obviously doesn't make sense
here, but it was copied from something else.
And
and then all of these fields you see
here in the middle,
which are, you know, configuring the actual device,
those could all be in exposed in some
way or another, mapped in some way or
another to the abstract type that we created.
So in this case, we're just saying that
we want the host name to be exposed
on it.
But especially it's especially useful if you have
something that has, like, a common configuration across.
So you could have maybe a map
that was
on packet or on Equinix metal mapped, you
know, or small to c one small x
86.
And on AWS, it was like, you know,
AWS standard two or whatever, you know, their
instance types are called. You can kind of
map that so you can have a consistent
translation to to different backing things.
And you can have any number of resources
in line here. So we could have also
created,
you know, a VLAN or or any of
the other resources that are created
with the Equinix metal provider.
Cool. Alright. I actually I think I understood.
I'll say I'll I'll I'll be, you know,
humble. 96%.
But That's pretty good. Yeah. There's a lot
there's a lot of moving parts here. I'm
I that's better than I understood less of
it and I was saying it. So I
know. I'm I'm gonna have to ask Marcus
for a proper translation later, but let's
I'm curious. Right? So
this composition CRD is just a way for
me to collectively add this stuff together. Right?
But there's there's nothing I I could deploy
that on its own. Is that right?
Yeah. Absolutely. There's some fields missing here. Obviously,
you'll you'll notice that the
the metadata is missing, so you don't have,
like, a name for the device up there,
which is obviously required for a resource. That's
actually getting replaced automatically by the machinery in
Crossplane.
But, yeah, you can call this here.
I think that everything else
should be
okay.
So, yeah, this is kind of the the
original
kind of initial flow that folks will go
through when they're using Crossplane.
You don't need the name. That's everything that's
in the box. Is there anything that's not
in the box that you get? Do you
get something extra like our back?
With the when you say the box,
what do you mean? Yeah. So the the
package. Right? So the the
the configuration
package
or what are calling an OCI image
included
that
XRD
and
and The composition. To apply the composition to
apply for it. Mhmm.
When it when that gets installed or applied,
like like what David's saying, you know, I
could have just cube CTL applied this exact
output.
Mhmm. Is there anything
in addition to that? Like like, for example,
is RBAC being generated?
And this is coming from my
my knowing how things used to be and
how things are now and and wondering about
the changes. Yep. Absolutely. So in terms of
RBAC,
there's a number of different things. So when
you install a provider,
yes, we are creating the RBAC for that
controller to be able to control the things
that you install.
Some of the RBAC, we don't have to
worry about as much now that that Marcus
had worked on because we don't have namespace
scoped installs,
and we also don't have claims anymore. So
there aren't things outside of the provider
that say, please give me RBAC to manage
this. We're saying, like, you need to install
it. There is we have another resource called
a provider config usage, which kinda does behind
the scenes stuff
that it needs access to as well.
But also in the future, we'll have the
ability to request extra permissions and and ways
to lock that down and stuff similar to
how we did in the past.
A configuration obviously isn't starting a controller. Right?
So there isn't RRAC that needs to be
created and given to a service account for
a controller.
But in order for Crossplane to be able
to
create a CRD and then manage instances of
that CRD,
it needs to be given our back to
do that. Right?
And so one way that, you know, in
the past, the the package manager ran as
cluster admin,
and it could basically just sort of do
what it pleased.
Now Crossplane actually runs with a pretty scoped
role by default, and the package manager is
built into Crossplane.
And then we have a separate r back
manager. So if you run k get pods,
in the Crossplane system namespace or just all,
you'll see that there's an RBAC manager running.
The RBAC manager solely is responsible for handling
the creation of, you know, roles that are
given to either Crossplane
or to providers that are installed. Basically, Crossplane
itself doesn't produce any roles. It it says,
you know, I will put these labels on
this thing and ask the RBAC manager to
do it for me essentially.
And what that does is, you know, obviously,
there can be,
some some danger with being able to create
arbitrary RBAC.
So we isolate that to a single process,
and you can actually deploy Crossplane without the
RBAC manager where you're basically saying,
don't create RBAC for me. I'll either, you
know, just go outside of this or I
will manually create the RBAC myself.
So we have a really strong separation of
concern now
between that RBAC and
kind of the actual installation of these packages.
Another thing to mention in terms of things
that come along
with a
with installing any type of package is let
me grab this from my other
repo here. Every package so I left one
thing out that's also in this package.
Every package has to have a crossplane.yaml
in it.
And the crossplane.yaml
basically says, I am this type of package
and I intend to do these sorts of
things.
In this case, it's relatively straightforward. Right? We
don't even have any spec.
What you actually can do,
and more of this will be supported in
the future,
is add in things like, depend on these
other providers being present, or I depend on
these other configurations being present. And, you know,
the first line of defense would be, okay.
We just won't let allow you to install
if those aren't present.
Second line would be, we'll go ahead and
get those for you and install them automatically.
Other things you can do here is specify
a minimum Crossplane version itself you need. So
Crossplane will say, what version am I running
as?
And make sure that when it installs a
package
that, you know, it's compatible with that version
and it will reject it if not. And
then there's kind of like arbitrary
other things you could add in
to get the benefit, you know, that the
package manager will kind of set up for
you.
Cool.
That's a lot. I mean, that it's very
cool system.
Now
okay. Before I start deviate from your plan,
is there is there anything else that you
what are gonna go into next before I
I throw I throw a spanner in the
works? So so you are welcome to do
whatever you want. If you want to do
something else that might be interesting is we
could have you build your own configuration,
push it, install it, and get some of
that flow as well.
So,
you know, I'll I'll leave up to you
what next steps we do, though.
So what I'm thinking is I I I
always try to look at this through the
lens of someone who's just watching the video
either live or or or later. And they're
like, okay. How how am I gonna apply
this to my own workflow?
Now
I think it's really cool that we spun
up a Rawkode live and I'm assuming if
I hit refresh, we're gonna see the the
Debian one just chilling there too. But
broke my Debian one. I'm sure my fault.
Anyway,
we've not done anything with that machine. Now
what I was thinking, is it gonna be
as simple as can I just put user
data here and then have that do something?
How do what's what's the next step here
to get software running on this machine? Yeah.
For sure. So,
obviously, it kind of depends on the sort
of thing you're provisioning. If it's a, like,
database or something like that, you might wanna
run some SQL commands.
And it depends on how the provider itself,
you know, exposes information to you. And this
also gets to something else that I think
we're gonna have
a TVS on with both y'all,
hopefully soon.
But and I just dropped
in the editor here a link to our
documentation site that has all the different fields
that are supported.
And so you can look there. There is
a user data field, so we can do
that in this case.
But something that Marcus and I worked on
on the last TVS episode we did was
a provider SSH.
So you can imagine
if you have a composition,
you could put I think I think we
called it script was the the API type
that we created for provider SSH.
So
this this really shows the power of configuration,
I think. Let's say you had a configuration
package,
and in that crossplane.yaml,
you said, I depend on
provider
Equinix metal, and I depend on provider SSH.
And I have this composition which includes a
device and a script object in it.
And that script object has a reference to
the device or somehow is able to get
its connection information from it. I have an
abstract type that is, you know, device with
script run, you know, or something like that.
And I expose whatever fields I want there.
And then when I actually create an instance
of that device with script run,
it spins up a device and it spins
up this script resource
which waits for that device to come ready
and then runs a command on it. Obviously,
this is a bit of a contrived example
because the device here actually has a user
data field, so it would obviously make more
sense to just do that if you wanted
a one off command.
But that that kinda shows the example of
how you can piece together different providers though
to do powerful things with a with a
configuration package.
Okay. So
there were two points there, I think. The
first one was, yes, the user data does
work.
So we could do
I guess it would have to be here.
Uninstall
SSH.
And that would work. Right?
Should work. I I assuming that flows through
to whatever the packet API does or excuse
me, the Equinix metal API does.
So I would imagine that would work. This
field might also be I item potent,
and it might stop you from applying from
making this change.
That was my next question. I saw this
thing, and it's like, you know, this machine
has already
been deployed. It's already configured. So to modify
these data, I'm assuming
is the provider going to delete that machine
and then recreate me a new one? So
it won't. So that's that's actually a great
question. A lot of times in Terraform or
something like that, it'll say, you know, this
is a destructive command. Right? Like, this is
going to to make this change, we have
to delete this infrastructure
and
and and recreate it. So in Crossplane, we're
not gonna do that. We will say we'll
basically reflect back whatever that provider tells you.
So there's some fields of a resource which
are immutable. If you look at our structs
in our code, we actually annotate all of
those as immutable.
And I believe, actually, in v one CRDs,
I think you can have
API validation for immutable fields as well. So
if you for instance, if we mark user
data as immutable, when you apply this, it
would say, hey. Like, you know, it would
get rejected. Right now, instead, what it would
do if this is an immutable field is
it would send it off to the Equinix
metal API and it would say,
sorry. You can't do that. And that would
be reflected and your status would be like,
you know, this device is not in a
sync state. You made you tried to make
an update. It didn't happen. And then if
you then remove the user data,
it would go back to being healthy.
Okay. So
let's use this as a a learning opportunity
for me. Cool. I've now added a user
data, but we're also in a situation where
the machine doesn't deploy anyway.
So now if this was me working with
standard Kubernetes,
I would run, get the bases.
Is this ID the packet ID or a
Crossplane ID?
Your your Debian machine is there. The host
name of it is Crossplane. It was on
the top of the UI.
Right. Okay. So this is the name and
the Crossplane
object, but the host
Well, you've ruined that for me. I was
gonna have some fun. Okay. So let's check
out the immutability thing. No.
Let's let's not delete that. Alright? We have
we did get the machine. So that's mean,
that's pretty cool. So
we're assuming that's maybe immutable, but we're not
sure. Is that
what I'm getting?
I'm fairly certain it's immutable.
But let's see. So you applied it and
then yeah. Let's describe it or get it
or whatever.
And you're probably thinking in your head, just
stick to the script, man. Come on. No.
No. No. This is great.
Let's see.
Oh, we did get it in our message.
Okay. Mhmm.
Yep. The obvious has been so that's actually
just a transient error. So successfully requested update.
It seems like it it did go through,
actually.
Just do k get device
or devices.
This might this might be impacted API, I
think. So I think maybe the API allows
you to send an update to the user
data even though I think we've had this
discussion somewhere else.
Well, we'll see here. Yeah. Let's just I'm
gonna jump on the machine. Right? Because oh,
yes.
The nice thing about
the way we do this, well, you could
view it as nice or cumbersome depending on
the situation you're in, is that, you know,
we aren't maintaining separate documentation
about how our API types work.
They are you know, it it's gonna flow
through exactly what the the API of the
cloud provider gives you, or the bare metal
provider or what have you.
And so that way, you know, when you
see an error, in your events there, you
can actually just Google that and it's likely,
you know, somewhere documented in the issues on
on the Equinix metal side.
Or we see this a lot with, like,
GCP.
They have pretty good documentation on some of
the different errors that it can occur when
using GKE clusters and different configurations you have
there. So we literally just propagate that error
back. If they update the error that's returned
and then they update their documentation, right, users
just are able to use that and we
don't have to maintain a separate layer of
documentation on top of it.
Okay. So,
I mean, the good news is we have
to use our data. I have to say
since the machine, I had to meditate the
Equinix metal user data metadata API,
and it worked.
And it doesn't run, but that's because I
got the package name wrong. So that was
kinda cool. So, I mean, there's a whole
host of things going through my head right
now. It's like, how do I close a
few gaps and see? I start to use
Crossplane to do this kind of device management,
injecting the user data. I mean, I've got
two things that I cannot
naturally gravitate into now. One of them is,
is there a way for me who to
hook in to the Crossplane events that I
can then,
you know, SaltStack pick up the user data
changed and, you know, go across my plate
and tell it all to update.
And and auto scaling, is that something where
the responsibilities are deferred to somewhere else or
something that Crossplane made or does or or
may bring in later?
Yeah. So that's interesting, especially auto scaling.
One of the things that we've actually had
requested recently
is
it's not really auto scaling, guess, but it's
replication.
So right when another
another target unit, whatever that may be, comes
online to automatically
provision new infrastructure for it. So in in
the case that I'm alluding to here, it's
more Kubernetes clusters
being added as
Helm provider targets. And every time a Kubernetes
cluster kind of, like, pops up in the
Kubernetes API,
folks wanna basically have a Helm script run
on it. So if you have, like, a
service mesh that runs on all of your
your clusters,
that's kind of the use case there.
Right now, that's not something that's supported in
the core composition model.
We have talked a little bit about we
actually were talking about this in the community
meeting yesterday.
The idea of, like, a composition set, which
would be kind of, like, similar to a
replica set with pods, but it would just
be infrastructure or grouping of infrastructure
that you could have, you know, replicated,
you know, typically a a daemon set or
something like that is gonna be on every
node, but you could have that, you know,
every Kubernetes cluster, every packet device you see.
So that's something we've talked about.
What you can do instead of that is
you could also write a provider or just
a standalone controller
with kind of that logic already in it
and install it to do some of that
functionality.
So we generally try to defer things to
extensions just to kind of keep the core
cross by model cleaner
and also allow folks to have things custom
to their use case. Right? Because as soon
as we we go with a single model,
then it kind of eliminates
other options.
Yeah. I I think that that's probably a
good way to do it, it it's just
my my brain is just thinking about all
this other stuff that I want, you know,
to take care of me so I don't
have to do it. Well, open up some
issues, man. We'll we'll get to them.
Yeah. I think I mean, I could see
I could see exactly how I'd wanna use
this and and to manage my devices. I
love the fact that I updated that use
of data. You know, I can actually build
enough automation on the the device side anyway
to keep a track of that and make
sure that it's the reconciliation
never kinda stops at that that kinda wall.
Alright. Let's
pop back over here. So, Marcus, what was
this? What were you trying to I don't
know if it's a virus or if it's
a some sort of Monero minor, like, what
is it?
Are there? Oh, you're muted. Muted now.
You're still muted, Marcus. Muted.
There you go. We're just cycling
on me. I don't know why it's doing
that.
So there was an episode of the binding
status where
we were exploring
Tinkerbell.
And
I'm I'm trying to recall how how much
of this was
prebaked and how much of this we,
what, run live.
But this
this set of YAML here provision
the
think provisioner,
the virtual network necessary for it. And then
once we had that, how much of it
did we manually
have to configure or install? That's the part
I'm not sure about.
I'm pulling up the YouTube video right now.
I'm gonna drop a link. Just gonna watch
you gotta watch the YouTube video and let's
post the We're have a group watch here.
Let's see. This is the
oh, I'm not logged in. Well, here, I'll
put it
well, I guess if I just send in
the private chat only, I'll get it. It's
in the readme.md.
There's a link for folks. I don't know.
I don't know, David, if you're able to
put that in the chat or or whatever.
But this is us hacking for an hour
and a half and barely getting something running,
but it was interesting.
So having a quick look at this. What
expense of a device, there's no user data
here. So I'm assuming the manual steps you're
maybe talking about were did you deploy Tinkerbell?
Did I guess you SSH then, or did
you use this new provider that you were
working on? Is that why this
popped up? I I I think that with
this provisioner,
we manually
ran
did we create the provisioner? We ran kind
on it. No. Did we run kind? We
ran Docker Compose. We we used the tank
Tinkerbell
install
scripts.
Oh, nice. So then we had
we had the
provisioner running there.
And
was there and then there was a bit
of copy and paste, I think. But because
you need the you need the hardware IDs
and
right. So it it was a manual effort,
but
it what
the re the work that went into getting
this demo working was creating the ports,
creating the
creating the port assignments,
and
the VLANs.
Yeah. And I think one thing we can
see here is so this is, like, some
inline YAML again.
You know, with these different resources, we could
put them in a composition, right, and have
an abstract type. It was like a a
Tinker Bell instance or something like that and
kind of take care of some of that
that manual stuff for us. I think there'd
probably be some more manual stuff here, but
maybe some of the provider SSH stuff could
also be dropped in to create kind of
like a a package that you could install
to provision Tinker Bell instances on on
Equinix metal.
So it sounds to me like the provider
SSH fills in a few of the the
gaps that are maybe missing here for, like,
a complete I think just from my understanding
from a complete end to end. Is that
something we can use now?
I would say no.
We got it to let's see. I've even
pushed up what we had recently because I
need to clean it up a little bit.
And and it needs to be refactored a
little bit for zero dot 13. So this
can be a teaser. Right? We'll come back
and we'll use provider SSH.
And if folks there's also a TBS episode
on provider SSH.
So if folks wanna see how that works
a little bit,
then we can we can definitely do that
in the future. But I don't think we
could fit it in in twenty five minutes
here.
And and when
on the
on the Equinix metal side,
the sorts of resources that we would need
to support are the the
Equinix metal projects Equinix metal project SSH keys
so that you can,
you know, create some crossplane, some YAML for
them
to get those provisions. So
that that is a a work in progress
PR open
for that.
Yeah. I I thought I was gonna be
able to just hop right in the SSH
keys, but then I kinda realized that I
would also need to have support for projects.
When
you think of, like,
a Terraform provider, you think,
okay. I have support to create the devices.
That's enough. And then you realize quickly, oh,
no. I also need the projects. I need
to this. I need that. And sooner, your
module gets
huge. And and that's what that's what kind
of happened here. This started with permitted support
for devices. Now we've added networking support,
and then we'll add, you know, projects, SSH
key support,
fabric interconnects.
That's a a thing that we can add.
Yeah. Tell me tell me well, I'm gonna
turn into the interview here for just a
second. What is what is fabric? Because I
know when we are working on you know,
so we just changed
the packet provider to Equinix metal provider.
What is and and you mentioned, you know,
having an Equinix
fabric, I think, provider. What what is that?
Have you done a few of these, Dave?
Trying to fix some or thought? I mean,
I stormed off in a half, so I
only heard the latter half of the question.
But I'm assuming what you're asking to
Dan is what is Equinix Fabric? Yep. That's
that's exactly right.
Yeah. So, I mean,
I think that
I mean, I don't know where to give
you the the sales blurb or just, you
know, just answer it in one sentence. Okay.
So
Equinix is in a very unique position and
that the locality and number of data center
and IBXs they have around the world is
huge. Right? I mean, if you want to
run colocation or bare metal servers in any
of these locations, then it's available in API
and that's great.
What they don't do is provide a lot
of managed services on top of that. And
what a lot of people want to do
is then default to manage cloud services. You
know, maybe they wanna use s three or
GCS or they wanna use RDS as a
database or, you know, back table or all
these other things. Or even they just wanna
run some workloads on a hybrid cloud or
multi cloud fashion. So they wanna split their
workloads across,
bare metal. They've got virtualization with easy to
and all this other stuff. So really, you
know, modern applications aren't just sticking on a
server and walk away or even a single
Kubernetes cluster probably isn't the default or what
the default in this near future.
What fabric does is actually gives you a
fiber backbone to all of these different cloud
providers. So you can have servers and an
Equinix IBX. You can have some workloads running
on EC two or on GCS, and you
can consume their managed services without going over
the public Internet and taking the hat on
latency
or even the ingress and egress cost of
going in and out of Amazon can actually
add up really expensively.
So that's what fabric is. It's like you
can just pick and choose all the cool
bits that you want from the various providers
and still have that choice and flexibility.
It's really important for multi cloud or hybrid
cloud.
I don't know if that was the quick
answer of the sales pitch. And if in
did I get anything wrong there, Marcus?
No. That sounded sounds great to me. I
just linked in our shared chat.
I I added a link to
Alright. Cool. Yeah. That's something fair. Yeah. I
mean, it's definitely one of the things I'm
most excited about, you know, having now being
at a packet now Equinix Meadow for the
last three months, you know, the the idea
and the potential that I can see for
a product of this is and I'm not
gonna get two sales pitches, not point of
the stream. But I see a lot of
really cool use cases for that. And I'm
looking forward to exploring hybrid cloud workloads with
it. So and Crossplane
needs to support it just for me now.
So, you know, we're gonna have to kinda
get that added to the to the provider
over the coming weeks or months or whatever.
For sure. Is there an API for
Equinix Fabric yet?
There is. There is an API.
So you can
I don't know? Do I have it enabled
on my account? I do. So,
I mean, the fact that it's here in
the UI means there's an API as well.
I'm not gonna point to the API documentation,
but you can feel free to go and
find that. And I'll put a link in
the show notes. But, you know, you can
come here and click connections, and we've got
a few different options here
that allows you to get started in the
process of fabric.
I don't know if it's automatically approved or
if it has manual just now as we
roll it out. I don't know if Marcus
knows better than me there.
Yeah. I'm not sure if it's if it's
beta stage right now or if this is
GA. I don't know if, like, there's a
special target we're seeing. I'm just question that
went running through my head. But the documentation
is there, which is probably a good sign.
I don't know how quickly the API responds
right now to these requests. I think that
there is probably some level of
verification
right now.
On the Equinix
API side, I know it's possible to provision
fabric once once you've got your account created
there.
And this API
needs some information from that API,
So there's a, you know, a little bit
of hand holding you have to do yourself.
What another thing that I'd like to share,
if I can dig it up, is that
the
the Terraform
provider
for Equinix has some examples of how you
can
of how you can use, say, the Google
and the Amazon and Azure, like, link them
all up through their
through Equinix Fiber
to
create one, like, humongous
cloud network.
So Humongous cloud network. Oh, they can't Yeah.
Anyway, that that's Trademark. My marketing. Yeah. That
was my marketing. I didn't go with that.
But Equinix Metal can also be connected in
in those same sort of ways. And
one of the things that we'd like to
be able to do
in terms of Crossplane is be able to
take advantage of all of the resources that
are native to
Equinix Metal API,
turn them into something that you can provision
in Kubernetes,
and imagine you're in Kubernetes. And and another
one of those resources that we can't control
right now because we haven't created
we haven't written it into the provider yet.
But you can provision these bare metal servers,
the networks,
all their interconnects to other clouds,
provision
the BGP networks and control those all from
Kubernetes. Like,
I'm in this weird spot of, like, building
these tools and not quite knowing what to
do with them, but it sounds like I
could do a lot of things with them.
Yeah. So so could you, like,
let's say, provision a device on Equinix metal
and then some of this fabric
stuff,
and then, like, a database on Azure and
then just have connectivity between them? Is that
is that kind of along the lines of
what you're talking about? Like, could you make
use of these other providers
and the resource they can provision and then
have that connection to them via fabric?
Yeah. And so you're you're you're
getting
you're getting the latency drop, the the reduced
latency. You're getting
I I believe there's gonna be some difference
in what you're paying for throughput
since you're, like, within the same facility.
Mhmm.
Again, we're we're talking about three different providers
in this case. We're talking about Equinix middle
middle Equinix
and, like, Azure or AWS or whoever. So
each of them has some different policies around
this. But
in the end, the the capabilities are on
there.
Right? Yeah. That's one of the examples that
I really like
was one where there was, like, ECQ nodes
and packet devices being bridged together
for a
for a single cluster. I
that's the kind of thing that this enables.
Yeah. We should definitely put together a configuration
package that has, like, a bunch of different
examples of these in that. And then you
can just, you know, install configuration that you
have all the different, like,
you know, Equinix fabric metal things
that you can just try them out, you
know, immediately if you have a Kubernetes cluster.
That'd be pretty sweet.
Yeah. I agree. Definitely. So what I'm gonna
say is we'll kinda let's wrap this up
now. I think there's a few follow ups
that we need to agree. And I I
think the best way for me to do
that is just to get you to confirm
now so that you can't back out. But
I think what we've agreed there is that
there's still some work to do in the
Crossplane provider. We wanna build out more support
from all these objects.
You know, it's October. There is Oktoberfest.
I always find that it's
when I'm looking for new things that I
can go and contribute to, one of the
most daunting things is just where to start.
So I think it would be really cool
if the three of us could maybe find
some time and it doesn't have to be
tomorrow or, you know, or next week. But
maybe just to show people how to get
involved in writing a Crossplane provider support in
a new Equinix metal API and and walking
through the process. And one of the things
that always trips me up again when I
especially coming to a project like this is
I always feel like I should submit a
PR with a test.
I never know how to write the test.
So, you know,
having something like this where we can show
people how to do that, I think would
be really beneficial and hope to drive more
support as a provider.
And Marcus, think we definitely need to start,
you know, showing off the fabric stuff. I'm
looking forward to playing with us a bit
more now that it's coming available.
So really exciting stuff, and we've got lots
more content to come.
Is there anything that either of you would
like to close on before we finish up?
No. That sounds that sounds pretty good to
me. Folks are interested just generally in Crossplane
providers.
If you go and look at the the
TVS playlist on the Crossplane YouTube channel, there's
a few different examples of bootstrapping new providers,
which should give you some context on, you
know, how to contribute to the Equinix metal
one.
And then also in either
I I guess it's still packet Slack. I
don't know if it or Equinix Metal Slack
and Crossplane Slack are both great places or
on Twitter to reach any of us.
So, yeah, definitely reach out and
we'll we'll go the extra mile to make
sure you're able to contribute.
That sounds awesome. And from Premier Marcus.
Yeah. Thanks for asking all the right questions,
David, join this conversation.
And
and also, it's cool for me to just,
like, sit back and listen to Dan finally,
like, explain to me, like, have the time,
the window to explain
all the changes that have happened in Crossplane
over the last two versions.
Yeah. The
things have been called
there were different names for some of the
same features, but they've evolved and they've evolved
in, like, powerful ways. So I still have
the old names in my head, but they're
not those old things. They are new things
that that Right. Can be used in
bigger and better ways and took a lot
of work together there. So I'm glad to
see that. Yeah. For sure. Well, we we
definitely
or I guess I I'll speak for myself
for sure working on the package manager, was
something that you originally
kinda got started.
Definitely was was nice to have all the
ideas that you recorded from all that and
that sort of thing and build on on
the work that you did. So definitely appreciate
that. And and and the the the functionality
today comes from the work that you did
as well. So I'm loving the good vibes
here, man. This is gonna make me tear
up. So
yeah. This was really cool. Crossplane is really
exciting. I'm looking forward to playing with us
more. I'm looking forward to hopefully contribute and
and help him with some of these API
gaps. And I really hope that we can
come back around full circle here in a
month or whatever and really show this off
as well. And I'm gonna commit you to
showing off the SSH provider too. So we'll
get that ready. Got it. There there was
a lot of things we said we're also
gonna be in the show notes. So let
me catch up with you both afterwards. We'll
get make sure that we haven't messed anything
and we'll get all that included. So anything
we said will be there, we'll hopefully be
there. Thank you again, both of you, for
joining me. This is a really good session.
I enjoyed it. Yep. Thank you. You have
a good one. Have a great day. Thanks
again. Bye. Bye.